One thing that I pride myself in is getting creative in the kitchen
when I feel like there's nothing to make.
So that was tonight. I went into the fridge, pantry,
I felt like we had nothing to eat,
but I did see this bag of masa harina,
and I was like, okay,
you know what? Let's make some corn tortillas.
We made the corn tortillas.
It's just masa harina and water and a little bit of salt.
We rolled them out. We also had a thawed roast beef roast.
We chopped that up, cooked that,
and we also had one very large sweet potato.
We diced that, we roasted it,
and then we assembled everything.
We had a homemade tortilla.
They turned out so good, so soft.
We put in some of our homemade pickled radishes,
are sweet potatoes, a big dollop of sour cream,
and honestly, it turned out to be one of the best meals of the week.
So sometimes when you're feeling like,
you know what? We have nothing to eat,
you just gotta get creative,
because that's where the magic happens.